[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show what unites us as americans
is far greater than what divides us now
two-thirds of college-educated
millennials live and work in just
52 u.s metro areas this morning we
introduce you to
lead for america a program designed to
bring young talent back home
after college to help build up their
under-resourced communities
adriana diaz spoke with one of the
program's founders and three of his
fellows
about what homecoming means to them
the quiet of wilson north carolina is
only interrupted
when the outside world rolls through
i want to get you up here this is home
for 25 year old dante pittman
and the last place he thought he'd be
after going to unc
chapel hill and working as the state
attorney general's assistant in raleigh
most of the folks that i polled said i
should stay right where i was
but thank goodness for good family who
said you need to come on back home
he did to work for the city of wilson
thanks to lead for america
a non-profit that provides college grads
with two-year fellowships
in their home towns i feel like every
day i have the opportunity to change
someone's life our generation wants to
have
a tremendous impact on our communities
in my opinion the best way to do that is
to go back to where you started forget
about that shiny big city
yeah well you know i first time i went
to new york i saw a 10 pound rat so it's
not that shiny
[Laughter]
25 year old benja krauss all right see
you
soon helped create lead for america so
that hometowns everywhere
can hold on to homegrown talent that is
amazing
her family's been in small town wauseeka
minnesota for
six generations what is the impact of
the brain drain that happens when
you know people go off to college and
then they don't come back
there's a material cost to what happens
when there's brain drain rate
we see rural hospitals closing schools
unable to find teachers
i think that also sends this feeling
that there's not much hope
that this place isn't one that that is
appealing for bright people
the two-year-old program has placed
almost a hundred fellows and jobs
back home that includes small towns
rural lands tribal communities
and also economically distressed urban
neighborhoods
neighborhoods like north st louis where
23 year old
trayvon latimer grew up it was a place
that i had a heart for and wanted to see
change but
didn't necessarily have the tools
i did spend a lot of my childhood in
ferguson missouri i definitely thought a
lot about you know inequality those
issues
after college in chicago latimer came
home to work on those issues
with the fellowship supporting small and
minority owned businesses
the federal stimulus at goodell passed
in march a lot of the money for small
businesses came through our department
so
i was able to help divvy out almost 5
million dollars to
small businesses across the region what
kind of difference can someone like you
make who's actually from the community
if you have people who understand where
they're from and understand the issues
more than anybody more than any like
policy expert because they live in day
to day you will see real change
i just got a ten thousand dollar grant
the fond du lac tribal nation in
minnesota
is alexandra houchin's home with leed
she's expanding food sustainability
for her tribe what does it mean to you
that through this fellowship you can
stay home and you can do the work you
want to do
it means everything it's i just feel
really
blessed to feel so believed in and it
keeps me motivated
thank you back in wilson pittman got a
promotion
he's now the city's human relations
director
i can tell you that being in charge of a
department at 25
is not something that i thought i was
prepared for and it's certainly not
normal
but it was possible because he came home
for cbs this morning adriana diaz
chicago so you can go home again that's
right
we take exception dante pittman we think
you're great but was it rat really ten
pounds
more than eight yes i was gonna say i
want to defend our new york city rats
they're actually very friendly
but it does show you you can go home
again and you can thrive
i'm finding people are having a newer
appreciation too for going back home
yeah and two years is a good amount of
time if you want people to stay a lot
can happen in two years
meet somebody you get a routine down you
might not leave at the end of it yeah
and i truly feel like i'm living the
dream here in the big city but my heart
is in seattle washington where i was
raised so often times i think about what
i could be doing in the communities
that i was raised in um but sometimes
you have to leave your city i think
that's true take over
the world to appreciate it and also
learn a little bit more because a little
bit more worldly and then you can come
back and provide more
you're bringing back you're bringing
home more well you're still taking over
the world part
mr sportscaster thank you yeah i just
think that's so cool